hey what's up guys I'm kabhi HD here and
while a lot of people may argue or like
to say that smartphones have been
getting a little more stagnant or a
little boring lately I would argue that
the rise of super inexpensive really
good smartphones is a pretty exciting
benefit to how good the tech has gotten
recently in other words good smart
phones have gotten really cheap and
cheap smartphones have gotten really
good and this out of nowhere is ZTE axon
7 is a really good example of that it's
one of those smart phones where you've
either heard about it a lot recently or
never heard of it at all and that's fine
either way consider it in the running
for best budget smart phone right now
it's going for 400 bucks off contract in
the US so right alongside the oneplus 3
now if you're considering buying this
one then you should consider my five
pillars of a great smartphone which I
judge all smartphones by whether they're
850 bucks or 350 bucks and that is great
build quality great display great
performance great battery life and great
camera if you have all five of these
things you're sitting pretty now you can
have other little quirks and other
little things missing and trust me axon
7 definitely does but as long as you
have those five things you're pretty
much set as a great smartphone and other
little things probably aren't a
deal-breaker
now those core ones and your set so
build quality axon 7 is built great it's
got the Full Metal Jacket and pretty
much no straight lines anywhere it's
similar to an iPhone with the antenna
lines at the top on the bottom and on
the rounded metal at the top the bottom
and the sides with the unibody design
pretty much no straight edges it's kind
of slippery since it's so rounded so you
can always apply the clear plastic case
that comes in the box if you want or not
or you can pick up a matte skin or
something like that a little more clean
I'll link to this dbrand skin below that
will help with the grip for sure but
then there's also expandable storage
with a micro SD card slot on the side
which is awesome and it has a USB type-c
port at the bottom with quick charge 3.0
and good well spaced clicky power button
and volume rocker and then up front
there's a pretty great display to bezel
gyeo here since on the front you're
getting a big old display but you also
get stereo front-facing speakers
flanking it and that's one of the phones
biggest strengths and speaking of the
front how is that display it's pretty
great on paper for a budget smartphone
it's a 5.5 inch quad HD AMOLED display
and it looks pretty great nice and sharp
gets pretty bright so it's decently
viewable outdoors and actually ZTE does
a good job with its built-in wallpaper
collection to really show off that
resolution so overall you can see the
media experience here with this screen
and these speakers is going to be great
the audio sounds great up till about two
notches from max volume and since it's
front-facing obviously it's a lot louder
and clearer than most other smartphone
speakers so this is awesome for videos
and games and pretty much any media up
at the top the front-facing camera does
interrupt the speaker grille for a
little bit but that's not a big deal and
then at the bottom you have your
hardware nav buttons these buttons they
work but they're not the best so there's
no backlight first of all so they're not
lit you literally can't see them at
night and then the strip of bezel Iran
is also super thin which looks really
good but that also makes the target that
you press a lot smaller so you can find
yourself missing presses sometimes like
I did it's kind of a quirk alright so
what about performance
well ZTE threw in the Snapdragon 820
with the Adreno 530 and 4 gigabytes of
RAM so it should be right up there with
other premium phones with the same
chipset obviously and this software is
et East Austin is overall pretty smooth
I wouldn't say it's lightweight though
it is packing a lot of extra features
and it's called me favored UI and it's I
guess somewhere in between the stock
Ashraf's
from oneplus and the fully custom UI
from like Samsung it has a bit of a
different look different icons different
quick settings different aesthetics but
overall it's pretty easy to find your
way around and you still have a bunch of
extra features like I mentioned stuff
like voice unlock or customization of
the navigation keys you can switch the
back button to the left side or the
right side however you want a bunch of
custom gestures for things like taking
screenshots or turning on a flashlight
or scheduled power up and power down to
start and end your day without having to
use the hardware
pretty neat there's power saving modes
there's a battery saving mode when
you're getting low it's pretty
full-featured but it is definitely still
packin some quirks to the software
quirks can definitely be ironed out with
updates but it's just odd to see certain
stuff like on a lock screen for example
every time you unlock your phone you
have to hit the little bell to see your
notifications like every time I don't
why can't you turn that off it seems
weird the only reason you unlock your
phone half the time is just to check to
see if you have notifications and nine
times out of ten it's really annoying to
have to press that bill I'm not sure
what the thought was there anyway the
fingerprint reader on the back also
works pretty well but it's not the
fastest especially after using phones
like the one plus three and the iPhone
6s but it gets the job done and it's in
roughly the same place on the back of
the phone as the Nexus is so I got used
to it pretty quick but yeah overall
performance didn't really have any real
major let downs so I guess how much you
liked the software experience will just
depend on how much you like the
aesthetics the battery life category is
a little bit more flexible for me
because there's also other charging
conveniences that can make up for not
having the best battery life like a
removable swappable battery or wireless
charging or fast charging so the one
plus three is an example it has decent
battery life but it makes up for it by
having the best fast charging in the
game so it's totally fine that it
doesn't have the best battery life in
the world so ZTE did not skimp with this
guy it's got the chipset so it does have
Qualcomm quick charge 3.0 pretty fast
charging but it also still has roughly
four hours of screen on time and a
pretty good battery life for a quad HD
display that's constantly on max
brightness for me so that's also pretty
nice to see and it's a thicker phone and
I'm glad they put the thicker battery in
there but yeah quick charge helps a lot
with this one now the fifth pillar is
the camera and this is the area where
you expect it to break down for pretty
much every budget smartphone rocket on
the back of the ZTE axon 7 you get a 20
megapixel sensor with F 1.8 aperture and
optical image stabilization but as we
know numbers don't mean everything those
are great numbers but they don't mean
everything so the pictures show pretty
clearly a mid-range camera so it's
pretty decent exposure which is good
news and the auto HDR does a good job of
leveling that out and bringing up
shadows really well but it kind of
struggles with color reproduction
and I found it pretty consistent we had
some sort of a warm to magenta cast in
all of the photos so I guess the good
news here is that it's consistently bad
the same way every time but it's fixable
with software so yeah you can see the
color accuracy is just not the strength
here despite being very good with detail
and dynamic range with all those 20
megapixels and then of course it
struggled hard and low light and the a
megapixel front-facing camera has almost
no dynamic range so overall mixed bag
with that camera
so in short exon 7 is one of the best
phones you can get for the price
especially if you're into audio again
the front-facing speakers and internally
it has a really high quality DAC high
quality amp 32 bit high power output
you're going to have better audio from
the headphone jack with this phone than
normal phones if you're into media and
if you're into listening to a lot of
music and watching a lot of videos this
is one of the best budget smart phones
you can get it definitely has its quirks
with the software but at the end of the
day it still has all the five core
requirements to me to be a good smart
phone it's got them pretty much locked
down so I'd say if I'm going to make
this my daily driver I'm gonna wait for
software updates to lock up the quirky
features but overall it's it's firmly
right behind one plus three for me for
best smartphone on a budget right now
highly recommended and thanks to you
guys for recommending that I check out
this phone obviously you guys are
blowing up Twitter over the last couple
days for me to check this out so I'm
glad I did I hope you enjoyed the video
thank you for watching and feel free to
leave comments of other things you want
me to take a look at tech related
smartphone or non smartphone in the
comments section below
again thanks for watching talked to you
guys the next one base